on it
do you guys think that corn you know you
know what that sounds like okay do you
guys think that corn is cheating no
yes no yes
Roxy does it in front I might see which
is it in front of me or I know he's
there watching if it's hidden it's
cheating everybody's like yeah you want
to watch it it's like it's like watching
another movie I'm watching it though but
if it's hidden I think it's cheating
because for you to hide it site must be
wrong yeah I agree don't lie about it
fine yeah I feel like you can
he's in one room and he's watching it
and he coming oh you're watching that
rubbish again it's like it's nothing to
me but you wouldn't get mad if you know
as long as he's not he's open with it
yeah would anyone here be mad if their
husband watched or boyfriend watched
corn sorry can I just say something it
all depends on what kind it is if it's
that sick perverted kind then yeah oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah
I mean if it's like regular normal
normal yeah any I'll be upset I don't
think I'd be mad or be concerned because
what is it what's what are you seeking
from this variety
but then again to me that's a concern
for me because what variety why do you
want variety let's just try this is why
naturally
I'm not saying all men cheat but men
naturally want variety you're telling me
okay you can take the best man in the
world if he had a Bus full of models
waiting for him every day when he got
home every single day begging to sleep
with it most guys are gonna fail
fair enough but I'm I'm putting my self
in it
if you want variety it's a concern if
you if you cannot exercise self-control
it's a concern if I am to exercise
self-control and you don't give yourself
that same parameter is a concern I'm not
saying I'll be angry but if this is
something to iron out it's not something
that oh this is how you are that's your
makeup that's fine because I know what I
want and as far as I'm concerned on the
foundational like morals principal
standards we match and so if we're no
longer matching it's an even bigger
concern and now we're talking about the
longevity of our relationship I don't
think it means that you don't match no
no but it's up because I know what I
would like and I say what you was like
what is that so I'm not not to watch
that and if if
you're telling me these are the reasons
why you watch it less eyeing out those
reasons so you don't have to if you feel
like the reason is just uh I just like
yeah and it doesn't mean he's doing it
every day or even every week knows why
they like it but everyone knows why they
like what they like no one just likes it
and I'm not sure but that's like but
that's like a female point of view like
to man it's just like a a reaction they
don't think that much
but then that's not why then that's
that's fine we don't have to but it's
almost like asking men not to be men but
no not necessarily because in my
experience I have what I have not
experienced that do you understand so I
can't even speak to it because it's not
like I've been with a man that could
explain his side of it all I can say is
from my once and if this is how you are
that's fine I'm not gonna like say
change it's you're just not for me yeah
it sounds like you're not it you haven't
created a space where they could even
come to tell you that they want you is
that it sounds like if they do it's in
private like they wouldn't even tell you
oh it's effective and this is what I'm
saying I wouldn't get angry to me it
would be a concern so if you came to me
or I caught you I'm not gonna be oh my
no no it's like okay let's sit down and
talk about it like why why why can't you
feel like you like this or whatever and
like if if you're like this is how I am
and I can't really explain it or
whatever
I have the right to say but I don't like
this I don't I don't have to compromise
on that so hang on can I just say
something because from what tell me if
I'm wrong yeah you're talking about
if like now if you found him watching or
if he suddenly decided yeah but
what I would say yeah and what I think
you're saying is that yeah this is you
wouldn't be with somebody that does it
anyway yeah and then if he happens to be
doing it there's a problem yeah and that
I feel the same way I mean if I if I
know that my man does it and I'm with
him I knew that he'd done it before I
got with him but everyone with a man and
then suddenly he starts doing it what's
going on why all of a sudden you started
you never showed it and I think that's
what you're trying to say yeah because
trying to change an individual is futile
to me okay especially if you do not see
an issue
like I don't have the energy to try and
make you see or even see it from my
point of view if you don't you don't but
I don't have to be I don't have to take
it do you understand or or like I do
have the choice I can I can just
tolerate it like okay this is that I can
tolerate it but my point is is then I
have a choice but before me making that
choice I want to sit down and understand
if I had a man and he wasn't open about
in the first place and I found him doing
it
you know what kind can you imagine you
know I've been with you for x amount of
years and you're saying I've always
watched it and I've been like I'm now
trying now yeah
but then that's choosing to hide it no
yeah that's when I may get angry yeah I
agree but if it's happening
we're going to talk about it okay I just
think a lot of times like from the men's
point of view it's like
we want them to be exclusive to us which
is like compromising on their mating
strategy strategy which is to spread
their seed but on the same time like
when they try to watch and I'm not
saying you specific I don't know your
marriage yeah but like when when you
tell them that they can't even watch
corn and that's cheating too it's like
well what do you want from me what can I
do so I just tell them straight whatever
they doing and then I'll try it with you
yeah
Auntie's ready to meet them in the
middle yeah I'll attract with you you
know I mean like you want to pick up
some tips but they're not going to watch
it let's let's have a go what's another
freaky stuff you know man don't slap me
either
yeah
I feel like corn has saved a lot of
marriages I've had a partner show me
something and be like
let's try this
really yeah were you down a rematched
she was down
I was down
because I knew he watched it or he'd
sometimes be like oh look at this like
he sent it to him and be like I don't
know how I'd feel my partner showed me
really if you sent your events and let's
try this tonight I don't know I feel
like I would be like and I'm not saying
I would be against it but I I don't know
I think that's about I don't know
obviously everyone's different but to me
for me personally there's boundaries you
can be watching it and doing all this
but if you're putting more attention on
that then me then it's an issue
[Music]
I think that's so badly mine is tell me
the first place because if I find it
later on I'm telling you it's just a
slippery slope yeah yeah just tell me
who you are yeah introduce me to you and
I'll choose if I want to be yeah it's
awesome I'm going to show you who I am
yeah I think yeah I agree as long as
you're transparent then there's no issue
so what are you on just let me know
no freaky stuff either yeah yeah
it's definitely important to ask what's
kind what to ask which kind yeah which
um because there's different levels and
you find that women might have set up my
at steps some levels but then yeah
certain stuff I'm just like yeah yeah
that's that's who they are as well yeah
your interest I feel like that's a topic
of conversation that you talk about no
yeah I know 100 like I wouldn't know
I've never had that conversation though
yeah I've never had a conversation with
them anymore I've had it what what
they're into yeah
not not in corn I'm saying in in general
in the bedroom like oh yeah you know
what they like and what they don't like
I'm up for anything because you're my
man in it but no freaky stuff
that's different that's not even copy of
nobody that's me getting freaky there's
a big difference yeah as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible